>> Will Sentance: Một trong những phần thưởng mà tôi muốn tặng cho bạn trước đây khi tôi nói rằng chúng ta đã chuyển đi
giải pháp ba.
Đó sẽ là điều quan trọng tiếp theo và
đơn giản hóa tất cả việc tạo đối tượng này.
Thêm một điều nữa mà tôi muốn cung cấp cho bạn đó là điều này.
Khai báo và gọi một hàm mới bên trong gia số phương thức của chúng ta.
Hãy để tôi xóa những thứ chúng tôi đã thêm vào đó để chúng tôi không bị nhầm lẫn.
Hãy loại bỏ những phần thưởng này ở đây.
Vì vậy, ở dưới cùng, bạn có thể thấy, tôi đang gọi hàm tăng,
như trước đây, đây là cùng một mã.
Điều duy nhất tôi đã thay đổi ở đây, dân gian,
là tôi đã đặt phương thức tăng làm phương thức duy nhất trong cửa hàng hàm người dùng.
Và tôi vừa định nghĩa nó qua các dòng, để chúng ta có thể thêm một số thứ vào đó.
Đúng vậy, đó thực sự là những gì tôi đã làm?
Tôi hy vọng nó là như vậy, tôi nghĩ nó đúng hy vọng.
Vì vậy, bây giờ chúng tôi chỉ có chức năng gia tăng của chúng tôi ở đây.
Nhưng đó chỉ là vì mục đích đơn giản, vì vậy chúng tôi có thể làm điều gì đó bên trong nó,
đi thôi.
>> Will Sentance: John không thích việc tôi xóa bảng.
Được rồi, có một phương thức gia tăng của chúng tôi đang được gọi trên user1,
thông qua liên kết proto, vâng, tất cả tốt?
Nó thực hiện điều này. Điểm ++?
Tôi chỉ đặt nó bây giờ để hơi xòe ra vì tôi muốn làm điều này,
Tôi muốn bên trong của phương thức tăng dần.
Bởi vì nếu bạn bắt đầu nghĩ theo phong cách viết mã này,
bạn sẽ luôn tìm thấy chính mình trong phương pháp gia tăng đó.
Một loạt mã có thể 10 dòng, 12 dòng và
bạn có thể không muốn chỉ có 12 dòng [SOUND].
Bạn có thể muốn chia nó thành các chức năng nhỏ nhỏ bên trong gia số
phương pháp, chỉ một dòng, nó có thể là 12 dòng.
Và bạn muốn xác định bên trong chúng,
một số chức năng mà bạn thậm chí có thể chạy bên trong gia số.
Mà có thể bạn sẽ vẫn muốn sử dụng user1.
Điều đó sẽ tạo ra một số thử thách thú vị và hấp dẫn, hãy cùng xem.
Tôi sẽ giữ cho điều này cực kỳ đơn giản và
theo nghĩa đen, chúng ta sẽ chỉ kết thúc this.score ++ trong một hàm.
Và sau đó chạy chức năng đó ngay tại đó và sau đó.
Bởi vì tôi muốn nói rõ, nhưng nó sẽ giống hệt nhau,
có một cái nhìn vào đó.
Tôi đặt this.score ++, hãy xem, bên trong một hàm tôi đang gọi nó ngay tại đó.
Đặt nó vào bên trong, thêm 1, và tôi đang gọi nó ngay tại đó.
Rõ ràng là tôi chưa bao giờ thực sự làm điều này trong thực tế, nhưng tôi muốn nói rõ.
Nhưng trong thực tế, chúng tôi thường tạo ra các chức năng nhỏ
bên trong phương thức của chúng tôi đang được gọi trên đối tượng của chúng tôi.
Và điều này sẽ thực sự thú vị ở đây.
Vì vậy, hãy quay lại điểm mấu chốt của chúng tôi tại đây user1.increment,
hãy gọi user1.increment.
Rõ ràng là không có nhiều thay đổi.
Tôi vừa đặt this.score ++ của mình vào một hàm nhỏ bên trong đây,
mà tôi sẽ chạy ngay lập tức.
Và, mọi người, đây chỉ là những thứ bổ sung mà tôi muốn cho bạn thấy xung quanh hệ sinh thái của
thế giới nguyên mẫu và từ khóa this.
Vậy là xong, hãy chạy user1.increment, Braden, hoàn toàn mới?
>> Braden: Bối cảnh thực thi.
>> Will Sentance: Bối cảnh thực thi, chính xác, nó ở đó, chúng tôi đi vào nó.
Điều đầu tiên, Braden, trong bộ nhớ cục bộ, tham số ngầm của chúng ta ngay lập tức là gì?
Cái này, phải, được giao cái gì?
User1 còn lại bất cứ thứ gì, vậy là tốt rồi,
bởi vì bạn muốn thực hiện một số mã trên user1 và thay đổi điểm số, user1.
>> Will Sentance: Điều tiếp theo chúng ta làm bên trong lõi gia tăng là gì?
>> Braden: Khai báo một hàm add1.
>> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời, add1, nó đây, hàm add1.
>> Will Sentance: Chúng ta phải làm gì sau đó ngay lập tức, Braden?
>> Braden: Chạy chức năng.
>> Will Sentance: Chúng ta gọi hàm, chạy hàm, gọi hàm,
chúng đều có nghĩa giống nhau.
Cái gì hoàn toàn mới, Braden?
>> Braden: Bối cảnh thực thi.
>> Will Sentance: Bối cảnh thực thi, chính xác.
>> Will Sentance: Bây giờ mọi thứ trở nên thú vị.
>> Will Sentance: Dòng mã bên trong là gì?
>> Braden: Cái này- >> Will Sentance: Chà, dòng mã-
>> Braden: Dòng mã sẽ là
this.score ++.
>> Will Sentance: This.score.
>> Câu di chúc: ++.
>> Will Sentance: Giá trị [LAUGH] của chúng ta về điều này bên trong bộ nhớ cục bộ của add1 là gì?
Có lẽ đó là user1 vì chúng tôi đang ở trong chức năng này, chúng tôi nghĩ gì,
mọi người?
Điều đó có ý nghĩa, mọi ngôn ngữ khác đều làm như vậy!
Cái gì, Braden, bạn có nghĩ đó là điều đó không?
>> Braden: Không.
>> Will Sentance: Không, [LAUGH], vinh quang!
>> Braden: [LAUGH] >> Will Sentance: Vâng, vì vậy đây là một trong số
những người được cho là, có thể không phải là những triển khai tốt nhất trước đó của JavaScript.
Đặc biệt là trong các ngôn ngữ khác, nó hoàn toàn tiêu chuẩn rằng trong khi bạn
bên trong phương thức.
Đối tượng thích hợp, đối tượng mà chúng ta quan tâm đến việc thực hiện các nội dung với dữ liệu.
Xuyên suốt, sẽ là đối tượng mà chúng ta đang chạy phương thức.
Ngay cả khi chúng ta khai báo các hàm khác bên trong và chạy chúng,
chúng nằm trong bộ nhớ cục bộ của chúng.
Nhưng không, cái này trong bộ nhớ cục bộ ở đây, Braden,
bạn có muốn đoán xem nó đề cập đến điều gì không?
>> [SOUND] >> Will Sentance: Mặc định của chúng tôi là gì
cái này?
Phải, Dan?
>> Dan: Bộ nhớ toàn cầu.
>> Will Sentance: Chà, đối tượng cửa sổ chung,
đặc biệt là không hữu ích tại thời điểm này.
Và vì vậy, chúng tôi sẽ kết thúc việc gắn vào đối tượng toàn cầu vui nhộn này được gọi là cửa sổ
một tài sản trên đó, một điểm số.
Sau đó, cái nào sẽ không được xác định theo mặc định và chúng tôi sẽ thử và tăng nó lên.
[SOUND] đẹp, tốt, đó là một trong những lỗi tuyệt vời đó.
Không phải lỗi, tôi đoán nếu chúng ta biết cách nó hoạt động,
no se không xảy ra.
Vì vậy, ngày xưa, việc này được xử lý như thế nào, nó là một cách hài hước.
>> Dan: [LAUGH] >> Will Sentance: Họ đã từng,
mọi người có biết điều này không?
Họ đã từng làm điều này, họ đã từng làm điều đó,
they used to do that = this.
Mà sẽ đặt điều đó bằng user1 này, đẹp.
Và bên trong đây, chúng ta sẽ không viết this.score ++, chúng ta sẽ làm gì?
>> Dan: Đó.
>> Will Sentance: That.score ++, chúng tôi sẽ tìm kiếm điều đó trong bộ nhớ cục bộ, nó không có ở đó.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi ra đây và lấy user1, không vấn đề gì [SOUND] không vấn đề gì.
Bạn sẽ thấy rằng = this bên trong nhiều hàm này trong suốt mã.
Đó không phải là con đường thiết kế đẹp nhất, và tôi phải nói.
Có nhiều cách khác để làm điều đó,
bạn thực sự có thể chạy chức năng add1, chúng tôi đang đặt cha mẹ vào cuối.
Ngoài ra, có một số cách thủ công để chạy chức năng,
có ai biết cách làm thủ công không, Kayla?
>> Kayla: Gọi hoặc trả lời.
>> Will Sentance: Gọi điện hoặc trả lời, hoặc ràng buộc, chính xác, tốt,
ràng buộc sẽ làm một cái gì đó rất gần.
Gọi và trả lời, chúng ta sẽ đi sâu vào vấn đề này hơn trong phần PR.
Nếu bạn muốn xem, hãy lặn sâu, những gì chúng tôi có, bạn có thể.
Nhưng chỉ cần nhanh chóng add1.cool,
Tôi có lẽ cũng có thể chỉ cho bạn ngay bây giờ, add1.
Hãy loại bỏ, bằng cách đó là rất tiêu chuẩn rằng điều đó. Điều này, tuyệt vời.
Tôi không nghĩ rằng nó vốn dĩ đã quá khủng khiếp, nó biết rằng nó khá ngớ ngẩn.
Nhưng có một cách khác như tôi đã nói về việc chạy quảng cáo một chức năng.
Theo cách thủ công, nơi chúng tôi thực sự có thể kiểm soát những gì nhiệm vụ này
là bên trong của nó.
Điều đó thật tuyệt, và đó là bằng cách chạy nó bằng cách sử dụng mát hoặc áp dụng.
Đối với bit này, cả hai đều làm điều tương tự.
Và nếu tôi đã vào đây, cái này, thì bất cứ thứ gì tôi vào,
cái này sẽ đánh giá cái gì, mọi người?
>> Braden: Người dùng 1.
>> Will Sentance: User1, và do đó cái này bên trong đây sẽ được đặt thành đó-
>> Will Sentance: User1, và sau đó nó hoạt động trở lại.